I'm actually supposed to be talking to
you
about constructivism today,
but I'm not going to continue to talking
to you about what I was talking last
time and I'll collapse the
constructivism lectures into one lecture
so it'll keep us on track.
I want to tell you a little bit about a
little bit more about this image and
what it probably means and then then
we're good.
We're going to continue with our
discussion of shamanic transformation
and its relationship with personality
transformation.
So the first thing,
if you look at the picture on the right,
the first thing you'll see of course is
that it's a tree and the tree is
associated with snake.
Now I believe I told you guys about
Linnaeus bells research and the
relationship between predatory state
prevalence,
acuity of human vision,
that you remember that.
Okay,
that's good.
So,
so to me what the image on the right
looks like is,
first of all it's like the ancestral
home of human beings for tens of
millions of years or our that's tree
with the snake,
with the primary human environment maybe
60 million years ago.
It's not human at that level,
but it's,
it's,
it's part of our evolutionary heritage.
And then it's also part of why we have a
sense,
especially that large trees are sort of
statement that's one of the senses that
drives environmentalism,
for example,
because environmentalists are often very
interested in protecting old growth
forests,
which is actually kind of weird because
old growth forests are ready to burn
down and they're also kind of
biologically dead.
There's no light can get to the bottom
and nothing grows down there.
So they're just trees and they're almost
dead treatment.
So,
you know,
from,
uh,
from uh,
from the perspective of biological
diversity,
they're not wearing that and
environment,
but human beings still have some real
kinship with those gigantic trees.
And we feel that there's something,
you know,
natural sacred.
So superimposed on that is I think
something like the next stage of human
evolution.
And so,
you know,
these,
these representations were made by
people who are trying to represent the
sort of,
the ultimate reality of mankind.
And so super imposed on the tree is a is
a mile and a mountain is a nice
representation of a pyramid.
And The pyramid is a nice representation
of a dominance hierarchy.
Of course,
I already mentioned to you that human
beings live in Darwin.
It's hard because in that there are very
permanent part of our environment being
at least 300 million years old and
possibly older than that.
So when,
when the human imagination is trying to
conceptualize what constitutes ultimate
reality,
that's a reality that's often beyond
what you could merely see because the
things you see that are directly in
front of you are not necessarily the
most real things in that many of the
things that you see are transforming
fairly rapidly.
They're not permanent in any real sense.
I mean automobiles to see all the time,
but they've only been around for 80
years.
You know,
it's not like we've adapted biologically
to their presidents.
So you have a mountain in the middle and
the mountain is sort of sitting in a
circumscribed territory.
And the idea there is that there's a
dominance hierarchy that human beings
inhabit and it always occupies a
particular.
And the dominance hierarchy is like the
culture,
the place of culture that mankind exists
within,
that surrounded by the chaos outside and
the chaos outside is represented by the
two snakes and be in the picture on,
on your,
in the snake in the middle isn't zero
growth,
it's a snake that eats its own tail and
it's representative of the chaos that's
outside of the familiarity of your
culture.
And so that's,
it's a very,
as we've mentioned already,
it's a very intelligent perspective
because it says,
well man,
I'm kind always lives in culture and
surrounding culture is the unknown,
and that's the internal habitat of,
of man.
So human beings.
So,
and then I showed you this picture
briefly and that's the picture that was
derived by a German researcher who was
examining the visions of the Peruvian
Amazonian Indians,
the Shaman.
And you can see it's almost staggeringly
same perspective right down to the snake
that eats its own tail,
which by the way is an extremely common
ancient symbol.
So it's quite remarkable.
Um,
now what might unite,
and then I talked to you about my,
my son's drawing.
I haven't given to get to this one
though,
or what might unite these different
visions say that Scandinavia division in
the Amazonian romantic vision are the
methods that the people who had
divisions use to induce them.
I'll talk to you a little bit about
that,
but first of all,
I'm going to tell you about this picture
because I think this is one,
a couple of variations of this picture
that I found.
I actually don't know his name,
but I think it's one of the most amazing
images I've ever come across because in
some ways sums up Christianity in one
picture.
And that's no easy thing to do.
And the reason I think it's important
to,
uh,
to talk about the Christian
representation,
for example,
that we've already talked about some
Dallas representations is because if in
so far as we're embedded in western
civilization,
the roots of Western civilization are,
they pushed themselves down into
Christianity and then deeper,
there's deeper substrata under that.
The religious structures that preceded
Christianity.
But if you want to understand the
western notions of the person and the
ideal person as well,
you have to look at the structure of the
systems that Western civilization,
Rhoda,
because the religious systems,
for example,
or the systems in which the idea of the
ideal emerged and so you.
You can't come to grips with the idea of
the ideal or the idea of mental health,
which is which is an ideal without
understanding the ground out of which
these ideas emerged.
You can't come to terms with it many
fundamental sense.
And the thing is,
if you're doing clinical psychology,
for example,
you have to come to terms with it in a
fundamental sense because a lot of the
time when people come and see you,
the reason they come and see you is
because their sense of life's meaning
has been shattered and and they're
unable to proceed without the
restoration of that meeting.
So maybe their belief systems fell apart
and they faced some sort of tragedy
that's just blowing them into pieces and
they have no idea how to orient
themselves.
Because life always presents us an
existential question.
And one that will deal with later,
which is life is difficult because it's
characterized by suffering and because
of that there has to be a reason to
stand up against them.
And so the reason has to be made
coherence,
so you have to know in some sense,
but you're the sort of creature that can
voluntarily face the tragic conditions
of existence and prevail.
And that's a religious presuppositions
fundamentally because it's based on,
it's a hypothesis in some sense that
human beings are like that.
So let me tell you about this image is.
It's staggering images.
So brilliant.
So the first thing you'll notice is that
of course there's a tree in the middle
of it and sort of looks like the tree
that you know,
little kid withdraw,
they sort of looked like lollipops or
something like that.
So it's a scheme of history.
We'll see of course,
that the snake is wrapped around the
tree.
The snake and the trees come along
together unbelievably often.
So asclepius his rod.
For example,
Asclepius is the Greek God of Haley.
And you see the symbol of the Greek God
of healing,
which is that Asclepius,
his rod are all steel used to represent
physicians and it's a rug with a snake
wrapped around the two and the state
represents transformation because it can
die,
it can shed its skin,
sort of be reborn and and for many other
reasons besides,
but in this representation,
which is partly derived for genesis and
then partly derived from the development
of Christian ideas for thousands of
years after that,
there's a particular idea that's being
portrayed now you don't want to set up
in the tree.
There are little things that looked like
fruit and one of those things is a skull
right now.
So the idea there is that the fruit that
the tree produced is in somehow is in
some manner equivalent to death.
Now in the,
in the genesis story,
what happens is that eve tempts Adam
with the fruit from the tree,
so she offers him this fruit.
Now that's a very interesting thing
because women historically speaking,
have been gathered like men do the
hunting,
generally speaking in archaic societies
and women do the gathering and human
beings have also a subsistent for large
parts of their evolutionary history.
Before we were human beings,
as we ate fruit and are we the reason we
have color vision by the way is so that
we can detect right fruit and right
fruit is also tightly associated with
sexuality.
So like if you look through the ads that
women's magazines,
the makeup adds the associations between
ripeness of fruit and say women's cheeks
and women's lips are always very much.
They're much put forward,
you know,
and,
and so there's a tight association
between sexuality and food for a variety
of reasons.
But so eve basically tamps Adam in some
sense,
into a conscious relationship with her
by offering him food.
And in the case of the genesis story,
it's rich ripe fruit.
And so that's an enticement and she also
entices him into self consciousness,
which is quite interesting because
number one,
women do make men self conscious.
I mean,
that's like that's the ultimate truth of
the,
of the nature of the relationship
between men and women and rejection in
particular is something that makes men
self conscious and they're much more
what exposed to that that women are in
this sort of sexual dance because women
are sort of on average,
quite quite successful at seeking out
sexual encounters where men are on
average,
very unsuccessful at doing the same
thing,
so they suffer a lot of rejection.
It's a very fundamental form of
rejection,
right?
It's like,
well,
you're.
You know,
you're good enough to tolerate being
alive and all that,
but your genetic material shipped by no
means be allowed to move itself into the
future.
It's a really fundamental form of
rejection and rejection is,
well you don't measure up and that's
certainly the ground of self
consciousness and so there's a lot of
weird things tangled up together in
genesis story.
So even gives Adam the fruit and what
happens is that wakes them up with the
stories is,
is that the scales fall from his eyes
and then the first thing that happens is
he realizes he's naked.
And that's a very interesting kind of
realization because to be one of the
very common nightmares that people have
is that they're naked in front of a
trout.
So you might say,
well,
what does it mean to be naked in front
of a crop?
Well,
it means to have your vulnerability
exposed to the arbitrary judgment of,
of the cultural mass.
You know,
it's a nightmare for most people.
And human beings are very weird animals
because most animals wander around on
four legs.
And of course that means the armored
part of their body is what shows right?
Their spine and their ribs along the
back,
which is pretty tough and hard,
but human beings are standing up.
So the most vulnerable parts of our body
or broadcast straight forward.
So and so.
When human beings woke up during our
evolutionary progress towards the kind
of consciousness we have,
when we became self conscious,
that was essentially equivalent to
recognizing our naked vulnerability and
that's what the genesis story is trying
to relate.
When it also points out that it says
snakes,
women and fruit played an integral role
in the development of human self
consciousness.
And so here the fruit.
That's the equivalent to death and
that's why there's this in the tree.
And so because what happened was when
people became self conscious,
like consciously self conscious,
we,
we started to understand the full nature
of our vulnerability.
And so what does that mean?
Well,
for human beings and in part it meant
that we discovered time like,
and that's a great thing to discover
because then it means you have the
future to think about,
but it's also an absolute bloody
catastrophe because you also understand
that the future is finite and that your
life is bounded and that you will end.
And as far as we know,
human beings are the only creatures that
have to contend with that knowledge.
And once you have it,
like once you wake up like that,
there's no going back to sleep like it's
a qualitative transformation in the
nature of experience.
And you know,
the genesis story pushes the idea
farther.
It says,
the fact that we've woken up when
they're are aware of our vulnerability
is also what makes us fallen creatures.
It makes us alienated from existence in
a way that animals aren't.
And so what that also means that this is
sort of an existential idea,
is that the rise of self consciousness
in that manner,
which is in part the knowledge of death
is also what's made people,
um,
well,
one of the things that happens,
for example in genesis,
it's quite a funny story.
So he makes Adam a self conscious and
then they wander off and cover
themselves up,
right?
Which is sort of the first entry into of
cultural artifacts into the paradisical
state.
That's right.
The first thing you do,
once you realize you're naked,
covered yourself up.
Now you know,
that story is often interpreted in a
sexual way.
And there's elements of that,
but it's more,
it's more pragmatic.
It's like,
yeah,
once you figure out that you're naked
and you're going to freeze to death and
then it's cold in the future,
it's like the first thing you do do is
cover yourself up.
You know,
when people have been wearing clothes
for a very long time,
we've been wearing clothes for so long.
The body lights are adapted to clothing
and so it's been tens of thousands of
years.
So you know,
and obviously human beings are also the
only creatures that were closed,
which is,
you know,
and it's a human universal by the way.
People were clothes everywhere that
virtually everywhere that human beings
have been discovered.
So you cover yourself up and that's the
first indication that you're aware of
your vulnerability,
but you're also aware of the necessity
of taking care of yourself as a,
you know,
as a separate entity,
which,
which animals.
Animals don't really seem to have that
notion.
I mean,
they get hungry and all of that,
but it's not obvious that they know that
they can extend the idea of hunger into
the future so that you know,
so,
so that they're,
they're caring about times that are not
here yet.
Now what happens after people become
self conscious to cover themselves up
and then God comes into the garden,
which he's always doing.
You have a walk with Adam and Adam can
be found.
And so God says,
you know,
well,
where are you?
What are you doing?
Hiding away in Adam's cowering behind a
bush,
which is really stupid.
These,
there with eve,
you know,
thinking,
I suppose that God can't see through the
Bush or whatever it is that he's
thinking,
you know,
he makes a case that God asks him what
in the world he's doing hiding.
And he says,
well,
I make it.
And God says,
well,
you know,
how'd you figure that out?
And of course Adam being heroic figure
he is if point Steve and says,
well,
it was the woman's fault for me,
but you know,
it was her that tempted me.
So it's really quite a comical story.
It's,
it's often being red being read by sort
of Patriarchal Christian interpreters as
a story that implicates implicates eve
in the initial destruction of mankind.
But from,
for my way of reading it,
it's just as hard on added,
were even worse because he's such a
cringing powered when things really
start to go wrong.
I mean the first thing he does is hide
because he's naked.
And the second thing he does,
as soon as these pushed on it a bit,
it's like,
it's your fault.
It's your fault.
You know,
we won't take responsibility for it.
And that's also an extremely complex
story because one of the things that
implies it's brilliant,
brilliant idea is that like,
if you can imagine metaphorically that
walking with God means something like,
you know,
uh,
staying in close contact with the divine
nature of being or something like that.
And having ultimate faith in the
positive nature of reality.
Things that might damage.
If you became self conscious,
what,
why would you stop believing in that?
Which would be to stop walking with God.
And the answer to that is,
well,
you become aware of your own
vulnerability and your own finiteness
and that makes you afraid,
so you'll hide.
And that is what people do.
They do that all the time.
It's,
it's a chronic state of human existence
that in many ways you hide from the best
parts of yourself.
But I mean adolescence is usually like
the painful acting out of that process
over a protracted period of time.
And people often never really recovered
from that.
They won't bring their best forward
because they're afraid and they're
afraid for good reason.
And so God says,
Oh,
well now you've done it.
You know,
we can't undo this.
And so now out you go,
you're not going to be in paradise
anymore,
which means you're no longer going to be
unconscious like a happy child.
It's like you've screwed up completely.
You know your finite.
Now you're going to have to work because
you're aware of the future.
And so you know all these things that
can go wrong,
so you're going to have to work because
you realize that the future could be
dangerous.
You have to fix things up and he tells
the women that they're going to suffer
dreadfully in childbirth very well.
It's very interesting because there's a
reason that women suffered childbirth
and the reason for that is that your
child's heads are too big activity both
about that.
The last time we met,
you know,
and so the story there also associates
cortical expansion with self
consciousness and with the difficulty of
birth.
It's bloody brilliant story.
It's just unbelievable how much
information is packed into it and then
that's,
that's very characteristic of archetypal
stories that also helps you see how the,
you know,
another manifestation of the kind of
tree symbolism,
say that's characteristic of the
Scandinavian stories and approving an
Amazonian and stories and enroll snake.
No trees without snakes,
no paradise snakes,
no ability of mankind to ever produce a
bounded environment that's safe without
something chaotic managing to come
inside of it.
There's no way you can do it.
It's a very paradoxical element of
existence.
So that's pretty.
That's pretty interesting.
So that's what's happening with teeth.
On the right side of the picture,
you see this skeleton at the back there.
Representing depth,
so that's good.
We'll leave and then on the on the left
side here you have the embodiment of the
church and the Christian tradition.
Now she's also handing out things that
are from the tree and so this is like
that.
The,
the religious stories in general are
stories about tragedy and redemption.
That's sort of what makes them religious
stories.
It's like the outline,
the terrible things that can happen to
you,
like in the most brutal possible way.
And then they provide a theory about a
mode of being that might help you
address stuff.
So that's the redemptive part.
And so the redacted part here is you see
in the tree there's also a crucifix.
It's sort of a counterpart to this call
and getting the tree.
They're all these little fruits and some
of them are obviously the apple skulls
that eve are handing out,
but what they are on the left hand side,
our hosts and the host is the little
thing that the Catholics eat during the
mass and the host is hypothetically part
of Christ's body.
And so that's what's.
It's a derivative of the last supper.
And so there's an unbelievably archaic
idea that lurks underneath that because
it's basically basically a cannibalistic
ritual and the idea is essentially that
if you can identify something that's an
ideal and you can incorporate it and you
do that most basically by eating because
that's how you incorporate most
basically,
then that can become part of you.
So you can take on the attributes of
something by incorporating it.
And so part of the Christian drama is an
attempt to inculcate in its followers
the idea that you should imitate the
ultimate ideal.
The question is,
well,
what's the ultimate ideal in different
religions handle that in different ways.
So food,
if for example,
is an ultimate ideal for Buddhists,
Christ isn't ultimate for Christians.
So then you might say,
well what exactly is this thing that's
ideal?
Okay,
so the host is part of it.
So partly it's the body of Christ and
partly it's a wheaton wafer.
And the reason it's made out of wheat,
just because we was regarded as a dying
and resurrecting crop,
because it's a,
it's a,
it's a crop that you know,
disappears in the fall and then comes
back in the spring like most
agricultural products too,
so it's kind of an eternal miracle.
So it's like the dying and resurrected
corn God.
And so that's a pagan idea that sort of
assembling the Christian idea and then
there's something that's more profound
than that,
which is that the idea is that the part
of the human spirit that can accept
death and die and resurrect itself,
which means to continually transform in
the face of tragedy,
is the thing that's the antidote to the
painful catastrophe of self
consciousness.
It's a staggering idea.
I mean,
I've studied personality theory for a
long time and the first thing that I've
discovered relationship to this as
almost all the personality theories that
we have that involved movement towards a
state of improved health are predicated
on the idea that people transform
through well through a process of
painful transformation.
It's like disillusion of part of your
personality,
which is painful in chaotic,
and then the reconstruction of that into
a,
into a more fulfilled form and the
reason that's associated with acceptance
of vulnerabilities.
It's van,
it's brilliant.
This is why the military is a virtue
from the religious perspective is that
you cannot change until you admit that
you're wrong and that part of you has to
go.
So you have part of admitting your
insufficiency as being willing to
sacrifice that insufficiency to let it
go so that something new rise out of the
ashes.
And sometimes that can be your whole
personality.
You know,
to the degree that your pathological in
your fundamental structures,
man,
there may be things that you have to
give up that are huge chunks of your
life.
So the alternative is to be in pain and
suffering and misery and that can turn
into cruelty and murderousness and,
and things that are much,
much more terrible than me are
suffering.
So that's the idea here.
That's a whole whole story of human
redemption in St Louis.
Mindboggling brilliant.
And you know,
it took people like took people
thousands of years to think about this
image or meeting ends of thousands of
years.
So there's so much thought packed into
that image is beyond virtually beyond
comprehension.
Remarkable amateur.
So here's,
here's some other representations of
trees that I think are quite
interesting.
So the first one here is a sculpture,
a living sculpture that's a
representation of a complete.
You can see how the trees,
the curvature of the trees and makes
this beautiful arch that is echoed in
the Gothic Cathedral.
So in the gothic cathedrals are stone
trees essentially being the treats.
And so in some sense they're
representative of the forest.
It's human human beings private home,
but they're representative of something
more than that too.
Because the gothic cathedrals are these
interesting trees made out of stone that
are also places of light.
Because what the gothic cathedrals are,
basically they're what they're made of
our is the interplay between tree like
stone and light.
This big glass windows of course,
are the light.
And so there's this idea that the
ultimate structure is some tree,
like call them.
That's invadable limelight.
And in some ways that's an analog of the
body and its and its function.
So when you say symbols that are
associated with is.
Well first of all,
when you see,
sorry,
these are echoes,
these are echoes of the tree like
structures that are with him because the
tree structure is a structure that many
biological farms statements.
So you know there's the,
that's the nervous system tree we're
meditating on for a bit because most of
us are convinced that our brain is in
our head.
And really that's not right.
It's just not that accurate.
But look at the.
Look at the dissemination of your
nervous system throughout your body.
You know your brain is distributed
through your body,
your spinal cord.
It's pretty damn smart.
It can walk by itself.
So for example,
if you take people who have,
who are paraplegic but have only,
they've managed spinal damage at a point
that doesn't,
they're no longer able to voluntarily
controlled their legs.
If you heist the off and put them on a
treadmill until the floor with their
legs will walk by themselves.
So because your spinal cord is smart
enough to walk,
I mean you need your brain to tell it
where to go,
but in some people who are paraplegic
have been taught to walk in a controlled
fall.
So it's quite interesting.
So you know when your spine isn't
stupid,
it's part of your brain.
It's just a lower part that's more
associated with movement.
But you know,
your whole body is full of central
nervous system.
There's more neurons in your autonomic
nervous system,
which is the part of your nervous system
that controls your internal organs that
the reason your break so you know
you're,
you're stuck right into your body and
the idea that you're,
you're in your brain in some ways.
It's like a hangover of the sole theory.
You know,
the Cartesian duality that makes minded
body something separate didn't united.
I mean I believe something do that,
you know,
it definitely underestimates the degree
to which you're an embodied nervous
system and that this and that.
The structure of your thought is
predicated on the fact that you're in a
body.
Like you're in a body cognitive creature
and you wouldn't think or be the way you
are without the body.
It's not like an appendage to your
brain.
You know how it works at all.
You can see the brain and the spinal
cord as and you can see the neurons
themselves as tree.
So the tree like structure Echos at
different levels of the nervous system.
These are very interesting
representation,
so they have a man in a lotus position.
Why Lotus position?
It's another tree metaphor.
So a lotus is a very interesting plant.
So what Lotus is is that it grows on
water,
so the water steve and maybe the top of
it's clear,
but then the bottom of the water is
very,
very murky and deep and dark,
and so it represents the dark elements,
sate of the unconscious mind or the
unknown,
that art that we aren't privy to and the
Lotus grows way down into that and then
into the soil below and so it comes out
of the darkness,
the soil and the darkness,
and then through the dark water and then
up into the,
into the clear light and on the surface
of the water it blooms and it.
So it opens up like,
like a Mandela,
like the stained glass window on the
right.
It opens up like that.
And in the middle of that,
the Buddhists sits in his trying either
position in the Lotus position and that
represents enlightenment.
And what the whole image represents is
the coherent ordering of multiple levels
of structure all the way from the primal
material up to the highest level of
consciousness.
And so the Buddha is like the ultimate
flower of the,
of the Lotus tree.
So to speak,
just as in Christianity,
Christ is the ultimate,
the ultimate manifestation of the,
of the tree,
of the knowledge of good and evil.
The very,
very analogous ideas and there's reasons
for this to it and part of it is part of
it is something like if your
psychophysiology was properly adjusted
so you weren't working at cross purposes
to yourself so that you are nicely
aligned,
straight up,
physically healthy and not defeated
lobster scuttling around the information
flow through your nervous system,
through your body and your mind would be
optimized and that would enable the
reality that you're attached to and part
of,
to through you sort of in an untrammeled
way.
You know,
instead of you're,
you're all full of bricks and trouble
and problems and,
and places that are badly aligned and
you know,
you haven't got the opportunity as a
consequence to sort of get access to
your own wisdom as you're sort of a bit
representation of who you could be.
And so part of this and also the like
the stone and glass that's represented
represented in the cathedrals is a
representation of the idea that there
should be a balance between structure
and light in you.
It's like it's the metaphorical idea and
that you should be properly oriented
physically so that,
so that,
so that you're in touch with the ground
of being in a way that makes you why
isn't solid.
And that's one of the things that
enables you to take on the tragedy of
the existence without becoming weak.
I mean these are,
these are roads,
so this is a,
this is an eastern Mandela and me.
What,
what it is,
is it's a tunnel into this tree like
structures,
like a cross section of the tree,
like structures and if the hip you're
looking into the tree like structure
down to the micro elements of Ba and
there's representation there about how
perfectly aligned and everything is at
every level of,
of,
of resolution and every level of
manifestation.
So he's back that are docs.
That's another way of looking at it.
It's the same representation on the
western side of things.
It's like that stayed last window is
like a cross section of the trunks that
make up the cathedral.
All these buildings like the medieval
people spend a lot of time building
those cathedrals,
you know,
those things were massive works of
culture and some of them took hundreds
of years to build.
I mean,
can you imagine modern people building
anything that would take like even 100
years.
It's like we want things to be up in six
months.
You know,
at most those medieval people would work
away for like 300 years on the cathedral
if they were really serious about what
it was,
what it represented,
you know,
they were trying to,
to produce,
uh,
the embodiment of the highest ideal in
architectural form.
You know,
and we've lost a lot of that even on the
campus.
You can see that because if,
you know,
if you go over to the sort of classical
side of the campus,
it's all,
you know,
cathedral like in beautiful.
And there's,
there's some,
there's some attention being paid to the
aesthetic element of the wisdom that's
embodied their knee.
Come over on this side.
It's a bloody like,
it's hideous.
It's a factory,
you know,
the,
the aesthetic is so terrible.
It's,
it's appalling.
All the buildings that are built to last
for 50 years and then they're outdated
and completely cheap and hideous and
cinder block.
You don't want fluorescent lights.
It's like come on,
you know,
and that they have you guys sit in these
things that are so uncomfortable that
you wouldn't put your dog in and then
you know,
it's,
well,
it's the loss to lose this sort of
thing.
You know,
there's a big difference between a
medieval cathedral,
a Gothic cathedral and this flooding
place,
you know,
but what you're supposed to be in a
university is something that's like a
medieval cathedral.
You don't want to say it's a testament
to the best that mankind has to offer.
You don't put it in a box like this.
It's appalling.
There's no excuse for it.
I actually think it's a conscious effort
to subvert the values of the university
because it's not a factory.
You're not factory products.
You know,
the university is here to teach you how
to be human beings and that's the
highest thing that you can aim for.
It's and to subvert that to a lower
orders.
It's the worst thing that can be done.
It's a crime against humanity.
There's no excuse for it.
And the ugliness that goes along with it
as part and parcel of the subversion,
it's like a hatred of the highest
values.
Terrible thing.
So
you know nobody,
none of you are going to go home and
say,
I feel proud that you were sitting in
this room know,
alright,
so now the Sharman are very strange
people and
it's very difficult to know how long our
kick people have been practicing shabbat
rituals,
but we know that it's tens of thousands
of years and we also know that most of
the shamanic rituals and the visions
that accompany them are induced by some
kind of hallucinogenic substance.
And it depends,
like it depends on the culture what the
hallucinogenic substances.
But one of the things that's interesting
about them is that they all have
basically the same chemical structure.
And I'll show you that in a minute.
So the sharpen people are chosen to be
shown on our.
Basically you might think of them as the
repositories of the oral tradition of
the culture,
you know,
because most cultures have for it to be
a culture,
first of all is it's a culture and it's
living,
it's been around for a tremendous amount
of time,
you know,
and non knowing literate cultures have
to carry that wisdom that they have with
them in oral form or an embodied form.
So in ritual for more in oral form it
somebody has to be the fundamental
repository of that kind of wisdom.
So this sort of the storyteller of the
tribe and the keeper of the flame so to
speak.
And that's usually the role that the
shaman have.
And they're the people who are contacted
when something's gone wrong with you,
if you're sick or if you're having real
trouble mediating with another tribe
member or someone like that or,
or you know,
when you're maybe overcome with all
because you're looking at the night sky,
you know,
it's the showman who's supposed to be
dealing with the realities that are
outside of day to day reality.
And so they're like masters of sacred
space.
That's one way of thinking about.
And sometimes they're that way because
their father was a or maybe their mother
and sometimes it's because they're kind
of peculiar,
you know,
there are people who are visionary as,
as part of their temperament.
And we know that visionary penis,
so to speak,
is an element of temperament.
It's associated with trait,
openness and that's associated partly
with intelligence,
but also partly with creativity.
And those things aren't exactly the
same.
So some people are more imaginative and
visionary than others.
And in our culture,
those would be people who tell great
stories.
Like j Dot k rowling is a really good
example of that is she's been a
shamanically intermediary for,
you know,
for an entire generation of young people
with these massive books that she's
written that you know,
have a mythological core right down to
their rate,
down to their essence.
And Stanley who ran marvel comics.
There's another person like that,
you know,
has had an immense cultural influence
because he's brought these ancient
stories back up from the depths and put
them into modern form,
you know,
and the writers of these things are
quite consciously aware of what they're
doing with regards to the relationship
with the underlying this.
They're not stupid people.
And even if they were,
their readership rapidly informs them if
they're deviating from the,
you know,
proper narrative arc of the store
because those,
all those superheroes have their
dedicated cults of followers and they
make bloody sure that the new writers
don't mess around with the story.
And so not only going to only is it top
down from the writers,
but it's also bottom up from the
readers.
So they're all participating in the
construction of it continuing cultural
apparatus.
So spontaneous vocation,
while you're sort of designed for
hereditary transmission,
well you know,
it's a familial issue and then there's
the personal quest issue too,
so that sort of associated with
spontaneous vocation.
So,
and the personal quest element with me,
there's always people in every culture
who are fundamentally obsessed with the
pursuit of meaning,
you know,
that's their essential orientation
towards life and not particularly
practical like a conscientious person
would be.
He was a conscientious person,
works you know,
and their,
their head isn't in the clouds,
but there are types of people who are,
are not like that at all.
Their heads are in the clouds
permanently and all.
They're extraordinary and magical.
There've been creative and there are
thought leaders in many ways for the
culture because a lot of what culture is
learned in an articulated sense.
A lot of what they become conscious of
is presented to them by artists in
somewhat unconscious farm long before
the full meaning of the,
of the,
of what's being portrayed as articulate.
Just like that.
You know,
I just showed you that tree image with
Mary and the church,
you know,
on either side of it.
It's not like the person who drew that
knew what they were doing.
They knew more about what they were
doing.
Then the people who couldn't draw that
sort of thing,
but they were.
They were existing on the edge of their
knowledge,
making this representation,
thinking,
I'm trying to get at something here.
I'm trying to get at something here,
but they didn't really know what it was
because the idea is so complex that you
know when,
when people have are coming up with it
over these thousands of years,
your periods,
they don't realize the full impact of
what it is that they're revealing and
just as you don't realize your own full
important
by whatever this is from Eritrea Eliana,
but by but by whatever method he may
have been designated,
a showman is recognized as such.
Only after having received two methods
of instruction.
The first is ecstatic dreams,
trances visions.
The second is traditional shamanic
techniques,
names and functions of the mythology and
genealogy of the plan.
The secret language,
the two full of teaching and is by the
spirits and the old master Shaman
constitutes initiation.
And so that,
that's very interesting.
Uh,
that's a very interesting representation
of the manner in which personal
revelation becomes knowledge.
So,
you know,
let's say you know,
you're beset by like a very frightful
series of nightmares.
I mean,
what that's going to do is to drive you
to try to understand how to represent
what you're having nightmares about in
terms of the cultural elements that you
have at hand.
Because that's what makes you saying,
you know,
if you're having experiences that are
beyond the norm,
unless you can incorporate them back
into your culture,
you're alienated from your culture.
And that's a terrifying thing.
It means like you might be the only
person that's insane like you and you
know,
it's very,
that's very intolerable for people.
It's bad enough to be different,
but to be so different that you're
incomprehensible.
It's like,
can you.
That's the sort of horror you don't want
to encounter.
So the Shaman or people who are are
possessed by like a rich inner fantasy
life,
but who are simultaneously capable of
taking that and weaving it into the
cultural mythology that they're part of
it.
That's what makes them saying rather
than insane.
Because schizophrenia is someone who's
has visionary experience which often
auditory,
no,
they hear voices and they're possessed
by spirits in a sense.
You see them wandering down the street,
you know,
monitoring to their,
to their own internal voices.
But they can't integrate any of that
with the culture.
So they're just,
they're gone.
They're lost souls.
So the Shaman is someone who does both
of you know who,
who has the vision,
but to incorporate it at the same time.
So someone who is master of the visions
of not victim of.
And so there's technologies that allow
people to do that.
A lot of them are associated,
as I said before,
with the use of various solution agentic
substances in Siberia.
The youth who's called to be a showman
that attracts attention by a strange
behavior.
For example,
the Sikh solitude becomes absent minded,
loves to roam in the woods or
unfrequently places,
has visions,
and sings in his sleep.
In some instances,
this period of incubation is marked by
quite serious symptoms among the yakuts.
The young man sometimes has fits of
theory and easily loses consciousness,
hides in the forest,
feeds on the bark of trees,
throws himself into water and fire and
cutting themselves with knives.
So those are ordeals in a sense,
you know,
a future show among the Tongass as they
approach maturity go through a
hysterical or history crisis,
but sometimes their vocation manifests
itself.
At an earlier age,
the boy runs away into the mountains and
remains there for a week or more feeding
on animals which tiers two pieces with
his teeth.
He returns to the village filthy and
blood state,
and it's only after 10 or more days have
passed that he begins to babble
incoherent words.
So you would think from the perspective
of modern human being says,
this is something like descent into the
unconscious structures that underlied
normative cognition.
Just like you descend into that at night
when you dream.
So very peculiar process that you are
all perfectly capable of engaging in,
have most of you have virtually no
control over it.
I me,
there are people who dream lucidly you
know,
and who can exert some conscious control
over their dreams.
Most people can learn how to do that to
some degree,
but in our culture at least most people
dream unconsciously and it's just
something that happens to you and not
something that you're actively engaged
with.
Strange behavior of future Sharman have
not failed to attract the attention of
scholars and from the middle of the past
century by which he meant the 19
century.
Several attempts have been made to
explain the phenomenon of shamanism as a
mental disorder,
but the problem was wrong.
We put from the one hand,
it's true that Shamans are always are
always have to be neuropathics or
neurotics are people who are not well
put together mentally.
On other hand,
those among them who had been able
became shalman precisely because they
had succeeded in becoming cured.
So what that means is these are people
who have undergone some kind of
existential crisis,
sometimes one that's induced.
You know,
as part of the process that turns them
into Solomon,
but they were able to undergo that
existential crisis and then put
themselves back together and so that's
what makes the masters of of the chaotic
ground so to speak,
and so you're starting to fall apart and
you don't know what to do while the best
thing you can possibly do is find
someone who's been there and come back
and that idea of going somewhere and
coming back is also a very,
very common mythological story.
So that's the story of the hobbit.
Truths at the audit goes off on this
quest and he undergoes all sorts of
trials and the encounters that dragon
that lives underneath everything and he
gets the gold from the Dragon,
which is the information that the dragon
stores and then he comes back to his
community and he's transformed,
but he's strange like he's going off on
this big adventure.
Now.
He's like,
well,
put together a tough.
And he's also rich,
but he's also peculiar.
When bill,
Bill,
Bill goes back to the Shire.
You know everybody.
No one's exactly sure what to do with
him because now he's contaminated with
everything that he's gone through CCS,
like an agent of chaos himself,
you know,
and someone who's somewhat terrifying
but you know,
useful if you have to have a
consultation about how you might deal
with the next dragon.
So
now I said that a lot of the shamanic
initiator editorial ritual seem to be
associated with a loose use of
hallucinogenic drugs and so the most
common ones that we know about our
mushrooms,
so for example,
there's this mushroom which many of
you've probably seen in fairytales,
right?
That's on the cover of fairytales very
frequently and now it's called a nominee
to miscarry a mushroom and it's
generally viewed as extremely toxic and
there's some.
There's some reason for that because it
can,
it can make the people who eat it very
sick and now and then people do die
from,
but mostly it's extraordinarily
hallucinogenic.
The Vikings,
for example,
this is quite a terrifying story.
The vikings used to take as needed
miscarrying mushrooms before they went
on there and pillaging trips and they
use the mushrooms to transform
themselves into the equivalent of
predatory monster,
so they usually,
they're,
they're sort of target was wolves or
bears and the word Berserk,
which is what the vikings used to go
ma'am bear shirt and so they would train
their young men to eat these
hallucinogenic mushrooms and turn
themselves into pain free predators and
then they would take them before they
went onto pillaging rated.
So you just imagine,
you know,
you're sitting there in northern England
and you're in your village and it's all
peaceful in these bloody crazy fight
cakes come all feel out of the ocean and
boats,
you know,
the open boats that they've traveled
across the North Sea it and they're all
like stoned out of their gourd on
Amanita must carry a mushroom mushrooms,
an old convinced that they're like
predatory bears and that's exactly how
they're acting and they have no pain
whatsoever.
It's like,
ha,
that's not a good seed.
That's not a good scene.
You know,
when the vikings come through and they
just destroy everything,
it's like,
so that's they're used.
They were used for Marshall,
but there,
there,
there were a drug that's used very
commonly by he goosing shamonic
experiences among themselves across the
whole northern part of Europe in Asia,
and they grow almost everywhere.
So those are the original magic
mushroom,
magic red and white dots.
And if you look in,
you can see these things in drawings
everywhere,
especially in fairytales,
very common representation of fairy
tales.
There is some evidence that religions
that are I suppose in some ways more
articulated and sophisticated in that
they're more articulated like
Christianity say,
compared to the more shock traumatic,
uh,
religions.
I have also have their roots in
hallucinogenic experience.
And this may be true to a degree that we
really don't understand.
So for example,
this is something,
this is taken from the manuscript which
is 11th century,
fundamentally 11th to 13th century
because there were copies of admitted at
different times.
What you see here is my mom and really
the,
that the snake is associated with
siliciden mushrooms.
And that's a very characteristic
representation.
And the silicide as much a minute and
the fruit that eve is feeding to Adam is
part of the siliciden mushrooms for
speculation,
you know,
among people who are sort of at the
fringes of,
of evolutionary theory that part of the
way that human beings levered themselves
up into increased consciousness was by
the use of machines.
We can see in the,
in the representations over there,
some of them are absolutely remarkable,
like the one on the top right hand
corner there,
that's Christ.
And he's standing there like,
like this with his hands up.
And then underneath the bottom half of
that circle is a psilocybin mushroom
with a head,
uh,
the,
like the main body of the machine is in
the same position as Christ's head at
me,
like the offshoots of the mushroom or in
the same position as his hands.
So,
well God only knows what that means.
So that's,
that's a very strange and remarkable
thing.
We really don't know what to make of it.
And there's a lot more investigation to
be done on that.
This is an Osca vine and it's part of
what the Amazonian shamans use to prove
their hallucinogenic mixtures and no,
none of the Westerners who've gone to
study the Amazonian showman configure
it.
How the hell they determined how are
they ever going to make their mixture
because it's virtually impossible to
make.
You need to take the vine and then you
need to take another plant that doesn't
grow in the same place and you have to
mix them together in the right
proportions and then you have to cook
them together for 72 hours and you have
to do that without breathing in any of
the vapors.
And you know,
there's thousands and thousands of
different kinds of plants in the
Amazonian jungle and it isn't obvious in
any way how the people who are using
these mixtures figured out how to make
them.
And if you ask them,
they say,
well,
the plants told us how to do it.
You know that for modern Western people,
that's not much of an explanation,
but it's certainly the explanation that
the tradesmen seemed to stick to.
And you know,
God only knows how people gather the
information,
you know,
chimpanzees use medicinal plants,
they're,
they're capable of finding plants in
their habitat they could eat that are in
math maker.
So one that helped them deal with
diseases and it's not clear at all how
they figured that out.
So there's lots of mysteries about the
origin of human knowledge,
that's for sure.
So the three sources of potential
visionary experience,
and this is very interesting.
So here's the biochemical construction
of hallucinogenic chemical.
So the first thing you see on the bottom
right is a serotonin molecule.
Now serotonin is in some ways it's the
major brain neurotransmitter.
The reason I say that is because during
the embryological development,
your brain grows out,
you know,
sorta,
sorta flowers for and it's guided and
its development by the serotonin system.
That's the system that uses Serotonin as
its primary neurochemical transmitter.
So it's not only in our very archaic
system and it's so old that you share it
as I've mentioned before,
with crustaceans,
but it's also the system that sort of
puts you together as you emerge out of
nothing.
And so you see it continuing your
chemicals structure there,
and then you see these are all different
hallucinogenic substances.
Um,
this one is suicide,
for example,
and they're all at the empty.
It's a very weird chemical,
very illegal.
He entity it produces if part of
IOWASCA,
although Iowasca is made with a plant
that contains dmt.
And then something called an Mao
inhibitor which decreases the rate at
which your body breaks it down,
like parody.
It produces an instantaneous 10 minute,
a hallucinogenic high that people were.
People constantly report contact with
aliens.
And there was a psychiatrist who spent
years documenting DMT experiences.
Every single person,
he,
he couldn't,
he walked through the experience with
recorded the same thing.
They're shot out of their body and
they're immediately in an alien
landscape,
full whack.
You know what that seems to indicate is
that from a,
from a purely rational perspective,
is that these chemicals produced
characteristic experiences that are so
associated with visionary experience.
They put you in something that's like a
dream state.
Now,
oddly,
the dream state seems to be somewhat
similar from person to person,
but there are ways that in some sense
that the young,
the contents of the unconscious mind can
be made manifest to the conscious mind
at least for for brief periods of time.
Sometimes that can be clearly horrifying
because sometimes people take these,
these,
these chemicals and have like the worst
experience of their life and part of
that seems to be associated with the
sort of thing that might happen to you
in psychotherapy.
So for example,
if you were convinced that your psyche
wasn't very well ordered and you are
harboring sort of dark secrets and lies
and all the sorts of things that might
complicate your life and all sorts of
femineity millennial pathology and
cultural baggage and like the horrors
that sort of live inside your brain,
you know,
in psychotherapy,
sort of confront those one by one in a
hallucinogenic experience.
You might confront all of those at the
same time.
You know,
and for,
for many people that's exactly
equivalent to a quick trip to hell.
It's not something they'd rather repeat.
So why,
why things are set up that way?
Well,
who knows?
I mean we don't really understand these
things so
we don't understand the relationship
between the parts of the brain that are
articulated and conscious and then the
lower parts that are sort of the
repositories of traumatic information
and there's deeper mysteries that we
don't understand too.
So it turns out,
I don't feel if any of you are familiar
with the term fee genesis,
but there,
there are studies of epic genetics now
that show that there are certain
experiences that alter your genetic
structure and while we know that partly
because when like if you put yourself in
the new situation,
a radically new situation,
new genes will turn on inside of you and
they'll coach for new proteins and
they'll build new structures for you.
So new neurological structure sometimes.
And that's part of how you can adapt.
And it's also part of the reason why
banging yourself against various
obstacles,
you know,
in a,
in a kind of what systematic way is a
good way of expanding your range of
capabilities.
So we know that experience can turn new
new genetic processes on that are there
sort of a latent prior to that,
but what we didn't know was that some of
those experiences transform your genetic
structures in a way that you can
transmit to your children.
So in that that's the Lamarckian
evolution and no one ever ever
hypothesized that that was possible.
But you can look it up.
It's,
it's mainstream science now.
Although you know people are still not
really sure what to do about it,
how to think about it from a conceptual
perspective because that sort of thing
wasn't supposed to be possible.
So No.
So we have no idea to to what level of
being your experiences can be encoded
and we really don't know how you encode
experience anyways.
We don't know what the fundamental
structures of your memory are,
how that's associated with your
conceptions of time and space are and
how that's related to your ongoing
experience.
Like those things are deeply mysterious
to us and what happens,
at least in parts of the gins is that
they seem to take all the horrors and
terrorist that you haven't dealt with
it,
just put them in your face now.
And that's part of the shamanic
experience.
And so it's not something for people to
take lightly and you know,
and generally generally people don't.
So.
But I've often found that it was very
strange that these chemicals produced
experiences that are so strange that our
culture instantly deemed illegal.
You know,
for me it's like looking at what
happened back in the Middle Ages when
the Catholic church we went after
Galileo because he had something strange
to say about the mood.
It's like these experiences have tapped
into something that's a very,
very primordial element of human
existence and associated say with the
shamanic rituals that have been going on
for tens of thousands of years and that
human cultures have always used to
orient themselves.
They're so added there.
There's so much anathema to our current
culture that,
you know,
we,
we punish people severely books with
very,
very peculiar behavior.
So although there is no doubt that this
sort of thing is dangerous and very
peculiar,
but you know,
so the seanad report relatively constant
types of experiences when they're
undergoing their transformative
experiences.
And here's a couple of them.
One is climbing the world,
treat.
We've already.
We've already talked about the world
treat and what that seems to be if you
look at the reports of the Sharman is
that they seem they're consciousness
seems to be able to to move itself up
and down levels of analysis that aren't
necessarily available to you in your
normal state of consciousness.
Now,
whether or not that's a real phenomenon
or whether or not part associated with
the dream isn't exactly clear.
So I'm.
Part of it is for example,
that you know,
when the show him with become convinced
that they can communicate with things
like plants at a very fundamental level,
but they are also capable of when they
climb up the tree for example,
of entering sort of the realm of their
ancestors and communing with them.
And I just read a book here recently
about the revival of Mongolian shamanism
and the Mongolian situation is kind of
interesting because it was a pretty
archaic culture and then the Soviets
came in,
they're like carbonized it,
you know,
which was sort of economically useful,
but socially it was napster catastrophe
because the Soviets were murderous
beyond belief and then in 1989 and they
just left and so the Mongolians like
they were completely up in the air then
because their traditional culture,
it'd be fragmented and you know,
the whole communist thing was a bust and
they reverted back to shamanic practices
and the shop and told them that part of
the reason that they were all suffering
was because they had lost contact with
their ancestral spirits.
And partly what they meant by that was
that the continuity of the culture had
been disrupted and so people were
identity.
This knowing.
It was funny because when Aleksandr
Solzhenitsyn wrote about the Soviet
Union and he wrote the volume volume he
wrote extensively about about the,
the Soviet experience,
his eventual conclusion.
Was that the best route for the Soviets
to take after the collapse of communism
would be a return to the sort of
evolutionary process of development that
characterized their exploration of
Orthodox Christianity because you have
to fall back to something you know,
because people need a meaning structure
and you know a modern people have a hard
time with incomprehensible religious
meanings.
Structures because we demand a certain
amount of rational clarity,
but there's a problem with that because
the absolute mysteries of life cannot be
formulated with rational clarity.
You have to kind of encapsulate them in
a mystery that's partially
understandable because because otherwise
they stay completely out of your grasp,
you know,
and you have no answer to the question.
You know,
well,
what's the ultimate purpose of life?
You know what?
You're not going to be able to get that
answer in a really tight box.
You know that you could open up in this,
just going to provide all the answers.
It's going to be murky because partly
because it has to apply to everyone,
but the fact that it's murky and
symbolic in a sense and sort of
multifaceted.
It doesn't mean it's unnecessary or
wrong,
and you know,
the more I've studied the theories that
underlying personality theory,
the more I've become convinced and for
me convinced beyond a doubt that that
connection,
our connection to the,
to the archaic structures of the past
that defined our culture.
So like without that,
you're without roots,
you know,
and that makes you a week.
That's the big problem.
It makes you weak.
There's nothing to you.
Every whim can possess you.
Every stupid political idea that comes
along is instantly you're gone.
You know when you're certainly capable
of going crazy with masses of people and
all sorts of insane ways.
It has direct consequences.
Do you have to be grounded in something?
According to a Yakut informant,
the spirits carry the future to hell and
shot him in a house for three years.
It doesn't sound very pleasant.
Here he undergoes is initiation.
The spirits cut off this,
have they set off to one side,
for the novice,
for the novice must watch his own
dismemberment with his own eyes and they
hack his body to bits which are later
distributed among the spirits of various
sicknesses.
It is only on this condition that the
future Sharman will obtain the power of
healing.
His bones are then covered with new
flesh and in some cases he is also given
new blood,
and so the the fundamental structure of
the shamanic ritual seems to be that the
death of the,
of the experiencing personally,
they seem to experience that as a
physiological transformation.
So it's,
it's the conscious experience of their
own depth and their dissolution,
right?
Great.
To you know,
the,
the dust and ashes from which from which
human beings originally arise.
What are the specific characteristics of
shamanic initiations aside from the
candidates?
Dismemberment is this reduction to the
state of the skeleton.
We are here in the presence of a very
ancient religious idea which belongs to
the hunter culture.
Bone symbolizes the final route of
animal life.
The mold from which the flesh
continually rises.
It's from the bone that men and animals
are reborn for a time.
They may entertain themselves in an
existence of the flesh.
Then they die and their life is reduced
to the essence concentrated in the
skeleton from which they will be born
again.
And that,
and then people who undergo these
experiences seem to,
as I said,
they seem to experience their own death
in a conscious manner.
That's a very difficult thing to
understand.
You know,
it's not obvious either for people who
aren't,
what would you say
who,
who aren't accustomed to those sorts of
extremes of experiences.
It's not obvious at all how much of this
sort of thing you have to become
conscious of,
you know,
because death is obviously one of the
things that terrifies people deeply and
it's not obvious how you should accustom
yourself to that.
So I can tell you a story that's quite
quite interesting.
I had a client at one point who was a
vegetarian and that actually turns out
to be irrelevant.
Part of the reason that she was a
vegetarian because she couldn't even go
into a like a,
a,
a what?
A grocery store where there was a
butcher's department.
Like she couldn't even look at the array
of neat.
It just horrified her and it was
associated with something that was like
a sleeping beauty complex for her
because when she was a child,
your parents treated her like she was a
fairy princess and they really protected
your from,
from everything you know.
Remember,
how many of you have seen Walt Disney's
sleeping beauty?
Yeah.
Well that's interesting and that so many
of you would.
You remember there's a.
When the girl is born and sleeping
beauty is born,
they don't invite someone to the,
to the Christie,
who do they not invite
the wish,
right?
I think it's maleficent in sleeping
beauty.
I think that's her name.
She's the one that turns into the dragon
of chaos at the end of the story.
Well,
there's a,
there's a message in there.
It's like,
do not shield your young people from
natural catastrophe because it makes
them unconscious and it'll come back and
revisit them when they fall.
Especially,
you know,
when they grow up,
when they hit puberty and come back with
force and if they're unconscious,
like if they're not prepared,
the horror of that will make them
unconscious.
And that's what happened to this girl,
like she was sleeping 22 hours a day
when she came to see me.
It's like she was a fairy princess until
she hit puberty and then she was like an
evil slopped as far as their parents
were concerned.
It was like bang,
things that switch,
things switched completely.
Of course that was horrifying to her,
but it was also tangled up for her with
kind of the horror of life in general.
And that was one of the things that made
her so sensitive to the saint at these
displays of these displays of me,
which are of course quite horrifying,
you know,
it's kind of remarkable that you can
wander through the,
you know,
maybe a little bit of discomfort,
but you know,
it's slaughterhouse stuff and you know,
to be normal is to be able to tolerate
that.
And that's quite strange.
She couldn't tolerate it at all.
So,
you know,
I took her to butcher shops.
Now Amanda,
because you do that with people,
if they have an identifiable feared,
it's actually quite easy to start the
psychotherapeutic process because you
start to expose them voluntarily to the
things that they want to avoid.
So you know,
I took her into a butcher shop and
cheesy,
don't just flipped her over,
you know,
she sat in the car afterwards and cried
for 20 minutes and told me about how
terrible life wasn't that she couldn't
live in the face of all this
dismemberment and constant death.
And she was also very,
very inclined towards identification,
you know,
with the little cute animals,
which is generally a fairly solid
feminine trait,
right?
Because females are very attracted to
things that are cute and cute.
Things are basically infant tile and
helpless.
Right?
That's sort of what activates the cute
detection.
You know,
it's part of,
of maternal behavior.
It's really an part,
you know,
because if you didn't find your baby's
cute,
you'd really be in trouble because there
are a lot of trouble,
you know,
and they.
And they push you because they require
so much care.
So they bloody well better be cute and
smiling,
you know,
make friends with you.
So,
so,
but,
but she would like was this hyper
identified with like little vulnerable
animals,
you know,
and,
and that's not good because she wasn't
just a little vulnerable Annabelle,
she was also partly a Predator and human
beings are partly predators and you
know,
maybe you think that's terrible,
but that's how it is.
And the predatory part of yourself
better be incorporated and used because
otherwise,
first of all you'll be weak without it.
And second of all,
if you don't incorporate it,
believe me,
that doesn't make it go away.
It will just go out and have fun on its
own in ways that are unconscious that
you don't control.
So she was a really good dreamer.
This girl.
And she could,
she actually had lucid dreams quite
remarkable.
And sometimes she could either ask her
dream characters what they symbolized.
Right in the dream,
you know,
is the only time I've ever seen that.
Although I've had some lucid dreamers in
my practice and one day she had this
dream because she was really having a
hard time finishing university.
It was like their sixth year,
seventh year or something like that and
that was partly because she slept all
the time and then she wouldn't get
anything done like she was trying to
sleep to avoid consciousness,
right.
To avoid being alive because
consciousness was too painful for her
and so she had a dream one day that she
met.
Actually I'm mixing two dreams here
together,
but it doesn't matter because it's just
sort of just sort of collapses the
narrative.
She,
she dreamt that she met at Gypsy that
was traveling through the forest and the
Gypsy told her that unless she was able,
unless you would be willing to work in a
slaughterhouse,
she'd never finished her degree.
So she came.
She came and told me that dream and I
thought,
well slaughterhouse,
that seems a little bit difficult to
arrange.
When she wasn't sure she could handle
that anyways.
And I said,
well,
is there anything that you can think of?
If you imagine something,
is there anything that you can think of
that might serve as a substitute?
And she came back to me about a week
later and she says,
she said,
I want to see an embalming.
And I thought,
wow,
that's,
that's rough.
That's no,
no,
no doubt about that.
That's rough.
So I phoned around to a bunch of
different funeral homes and I told them
that I had a client who was so terrified
of death that she couldn't even live and
that,
you know,
I want her to bring her to the funeral
home and walk through it and if it was
possible to see an embalming preparation
and um,
they were very understanding.
It was quite interesting because of
course,
funeral parlor people are kind of
strange people,
right?
Because they're dealing with death all
the time.
It's like they're daisy life,
you know,
and they get so it's,
well they're not dying of horror every
night,
you know,
that they are able to deal with it,
which is a good thing because we'd been
knee deep in bodies otherwise.
Right.
Someone,
someone has to do with this sort of
work.
So.
And apparently you can specialize it.
And so what that all means,
unless you think,
you know,
funeral partners,
directors are like completely gone human
in some fundamental way clearly
indicates that it's possible for a
normal person to become so conversant
with death that it's daily business and
you know,
emergency department people are in that
sort of situation.
And people who drive ambulances,
like human beings are bloody tough.
You know,
we can take something like facing death
and turn it into an everyday occurrence.
It's like,
it's kind of horrifying in a sense to
think that you could be that harsh in a
way,
you know.
But by the same token,
you know,
you don't want to run away screaming the
first time there's an emergency in your
life.
You know,
what the hell good are you?
If you know someone close to you gets
really sick and all you can do is whine
and sniffle about it because it's so
hard on you.
It's like it's not your attorney for
that.
You should be strong so that you can
help them.
And that means that we have to be able
to face these sorts of things.
So anyways,
we went to the funeral parlor,
which is quite a weird thing for me too
because I actually have rather squeamish
stomach kind of disgust sensitive.
And so it's hard for me,
especially odors just,
they're just not good for me at all.
But um,
you know,
so I could have never been a surgeon or
anything like that.
But we went to the funeral parlor and I
found it extremely interesting because
first of all actually need to know how
these things operate because at some
point you're going to be called upon to
deal with.
Maybe it'd be nice if you had a little
knowledge beforehand so that,
you know,
you didn't only have the grief that was
knocking you over,
but all the novelty that was associated
with trying to orient yourself in that
space.
So we talked to the funeral director and
we talked to him about how he sort of
managed his day to day encounters with
death.
And you know,
he said he,
he sort of saw it as his role to
shepherd people through the grieving
process and that for him and had made
them in some ways more acutely aware of
the affinity of life obviously,
but then also made a more conscious of,
you know,
of each day of the passing of each day.
And you know,
that might be one of the things that
salutary about facing your own
mortality.
It's like waste time.
Like here's,
here's a good question for you guys.
How many of you waste more than four
hours a day?
Okay.
So,
so I would say the reason you do that is
because you haven't really faced the
reality of your own death.
If you had done that,
you would stop doing that.
You would not waste time,
you know,
and we could do a quick economic
analysis.
I'd like to do this with people.
So what do you think your time's worth
an our.
Yes.
We know it's at least 10 bucks,
right?
Because that's
the minimum value society puts on your
labor is $10 an hour.
Okay?
But you know,
you're,
you're smart and healthy and young and
so each hour is an investment in the
future,
so it has to be considered in that
matter because you're one of your hours
is worth more to you than one of my
hours is worth to me because you have so
much of your future life still depending
on it.
So that's a big deal.
So I would say $50 an hour.
It's probably reasonable for what you
guys are worth at somewhere between 10
and 50 anyways.
So you know,
let's assume 50,
hey,
it's 200 bucks a day.
It's 1400 bucks a week,
it's 5,600 bucks a month,
$65,000 a year.
It's like you want to waste it,
go right ahead.
But that's what it's costing you at
minimum,
you know?
And you know,
you might think,
well no because I'm not getting paid.
It's like wrong.
You're paying for your studies.
You just get paid 10 years from now.
It's just deferred income.
And there's a huge difference between
people who have bees and aches,
you know,
like these door shut his doors open.
And so you know,
you wasted that time,
you will bloody pay for it and you don't
get it back either.
So you know,
if you're,
if you're awake and you know that this
is waiting for you,
and if there's only so much time you
have that can bloody well wake you up
and stop you from wasting your time
because you don't have that much of it.
This is a medieval representation of the
representation,
obviously,
because it's a crucifix and it has a
snake on it.
It's not.
But it's a tree snake thing,
you know,
and it's actually an echo.
There's a story in the Old Testament
about Moses leading his people through
the desert and it's sort of a,
you know,
they've escaped from tyranny.
So that's the previous place of order
and now they're in chaos because they've
left here at eight.
So they're all wandering round,
sort of without their heads.
They don't know which way they're going.
They're trying to run away from
something that's bad at,
toward something that's good,
but they don't know where they are.
And so they get all kind of,
you know,
fighting and break into factions and
then they start worshiping false gods
like golden calves and fragmentation
under pressure.
And so,
um,
God gets irritated at them and he throws
a bunch of poisonous snakes into the
desert because,
you know,
he's such an easy guy to get along with
say,
throws a bunch of poisonous snakes and
they're nickel run biting all these
people who are not being faithful.
And so all the people who are doubting
Moses are starting to freak out because
they keep getting hit by all these
poisonous snakes.
And so they finally called them Moses to
ask.
I'd be like,
you know,
call off the poisonous snakes.
There'll be,
hey,
I'm just calling all the poisonous
snakes.
And God says to Moses to build up like
a,
a staff with a brown snake on it.
And that if people will come and look at
this name,
then they'll be immune to the snake's
poison.
Or the snakes will stop biting them.
I don't remember which.
And it's a lovely story because it's
another exposure story and sort of means
that if you're willing to gaze upon the
thing that is most poisoned to you or
that you're most afraid of,
that that can help you overcome it.
And that's sort of like this and second
patient of,
except it's more complex because this
surface pale sort of stretches down
anything infinity that representations
sort of it sort of the manifestation of
the unknown right from the beginning of
time and space that's without even to
represent something that's sort of the
problem of humanity in some sense is
that there's an infinite number of
troubles stemming from a new source.
Remarkable representation.
I think
you heard about near death experiences.
I imagine the old idea that people see
the light at the end of the tunnel and
then you know,
wouldn't make get through the light.
They see all their ancestors there.
Something that vaguely resembles God and
you know,
and that's conditioned for some group by
their cultural background.
It's a very common experience.
And this is actually a representation of
that from the twelfth,
the twelfth to 13th century.
Anything by Hieronymus Bosch and this,
so it seems to be the sort of thing also
that's characteristic of the traumatic
experience post reduction to skeleton,
so the showmans dies and then as a
consequence of that,
he ends up in the space that's
characterized by the presence of the
ancestral spirits.
Whatever that means and me.
You can think about those as each of you
are embodiments of ancestral spirits,
right?
Because all the ideas you have,
for example,
are all.
They're all,
no there,
none of them are your ideas or virtually
none.
It's almost impossible to have an
original idea.
All the ideas you have or like the
ghostly remnants of brilliant
philosophers are theologians who've
lived,
you know,
hundreds or thousands of years ago in
your whole head is populated by these
states and they're sort of embodied
things because they tell you how to act.
You know,
they're,
they're not just cold dead ideas and you
know,
you're,
you're a mixture of all those things.
And I don't know if they ancestral
spirits that these visionaries encounter
are like personified representations of
the spirits that live inside their head
or what they are.
But,
but part of the experience seems to be,
um,
what would you call it?
It's like a rescue and the dying father
from the,
from the depths.
I'm.
Many of you seen Pinocchio,
right?
So,
you know,
the fundamental theme there right now,
don't use a marionette so anyone can
manipulate him and he's wouldn't head.
He's not awake,
he's not conscious.
He's not alive.
And so he can be led astray in 15
different ways and you know,
finally his father disappears to go
looking for them and for,
for reasons that aren't exactly clear as
father ends up being inside a whale that
to bottom of the ocean,
which is,
you know,
not the first place you think of looking
for your father,
but especially if you're a puppet and
you.
I like it.
A cricket was leaving which was all
observed stuff.
Although one thing I could tell you is
what's the cricket snake?
Yeah.
What's the initials?
Right.
So fake,
right?
Yeah.
Jimminy cricket is sending US Slang for
Jesus Christ.
And you know the animators pick that up
as a joke,
but it's not a joke because of course
the cricket serves as the conscience and
the spiritual guide on this,
on this quest vision,
and it's the cricket that leads the
pocket deep underground.
You actually attended to the ocean to
the deepest depths of despair,
right in death,
like a Chabad disintegration to find the
spirit of his father.
And why does he need that?
Well,
it's because without incorporating the
spirit of his father or his forefathers
can't be real.
And that's because human beings at
puppets apparently,
you know,
we're cultural creatures.
It's not like there's you and there's
your culture.
It's like you are your culture and so
you're either the embodiment of your
culture fleshed out and made whole or
you're just a fragmentary thing and
you're only half alive and worse than
that,
you can cope with tragedy.
I mean,
the way that Pinocchio becomes real as
he rescues his father from the whale,
which is also a dragon,
right?
The whales that dragon.
How do you know that?
What happens to the whale?
He spits fire.
Yeah,
that's weird behavior for a whale.
That's Pinocchio.
Lights a fire inside of,
but of course you know that's how human
beings have always escaped from chaos is
by using fire.
So he's the master of fire and that
brings them up from the depths and he
has to rescue his father and it actually
kills it,
right?
His father says,
no,
let me drown.
Save yourself.
Don't give.
It doesn't.
And he dies in the effort to bring them
to shore.
But then the,
you know,
the blue fairy comes down and says,
well,
because you're such a good puppet,
now you're awake.
You know,
it's a,
it's a remarkable story.
It's an amazing movie.
I mean,
it's a,
it has themes in it.
There's thousands and thousands of years
old,
like the idea that the hero has to
journey to the,
to the darkest depths,
to,
to reclaim a treasure.
The treasure can be lots of things.
That can be the dead father.
It can be a princess,
it can be gold.
It doesn't really matter.
There's this idea that you know,
the thing you want most is to be found
where you least want to look just a
lovely little.
That's a.
that's no chemical dictum by the way,
that the sort of reanimated buddy.
So anyway,
that's the idea in the show conditions
is that past death.
There's this opening up into the
ancestral landscape and that's the place
where you can commune with while the
ancestor gods or maybe the spirit of the
ancestors themselves,
which is something like God.
You know,
if you look at the Christian
representations,
for example,
one of the elements of God is God the
father.
And so God the father is sort of like an
amalgam of all the great fathers of the
past.
You know,
because you might say,
well,
what makes person a person a great
father?
Well,
careful,
devoted attention would be part of it,
right?
That's a transpersonal thing.
It's like if you're a great father and
you are too,
there's something about both of your
actions as a great father that are the
same.
And you can think of that as the spirit
of the great father and you know,
that sort of shines through individuals.
And so that's a way of communing with
God through the ancestors and that's
part of what these rituals are about.
I would like even now to stress the fact
that the psychopathology of the romantic
vocation is not profane,
it not belong to ordinary
symptomatology.
It has an initiatory structure and
signification in short,
every produces a traditional mystical
pattern.
The total crisis of the future Sharma
sometimes leading to complete
disintegration of the personality and to
madness can be evaluated not only as an
initiatory death,
but also as a symbolic return to the pre
cosmo mechanic chaos to be a morphous
and indescribable state that precedes
any cosmogony.
Well,
that's a mouthful.
So one of the things I mentioned about
this,
there's some
suggestion on the part of the artists.
This is a monster of origin point.
That's like the beginning of time.
It's a symbol of the infinity that
stretches on the fourth and that emerges
from that.
And so part of the initiatory process is
the dissolution of the personality.
The question is,
well,
what state of existence exists at the
level where your personality dissolved
because you're.
You see the world through your
personality and the world has given,
formed through your personality and then
when it starts to dissolve and
disintegrate,
say when you sink into depression,
said you're sinking into a state that
sort of before consciousness itself.
So let me tell you something that
William James said about this.
So it's very difficult thing to get to,
to communicate and we'll,
we'll touch on it a bit more when we
moved into constructivism.
So part of the idea here is that you,
that reality itself is extracted from
the unknown and the unknowable and you
know,
you do that as individuals because
there's all the parts of the world that
you understand and then there's parts of
the world that you don't understand.
You can't even conceive of now.
And then you encounter them,
especially when you fail.
And then you interact with them.
And by doing that you make them real and
describable and experienceable.
And so it's like there's this late
possibility that surrounds existence
that you can interact with and pull up
into actuality and that sort of the.
That's like the action of consciousness
on reality.
That's why,
by the way,
in the beginning of Genesis Genesis,
it's the word of God that produces order
from chaos.
Right?
And so that's the initiative.
That's the initiation of a reality.
And then later in Genesis,
God makes human beings and he says,
you're made both of you in the image of
God.
And the question is,
well,
what does that mean?
Well,
it might mean that God has two arms,
two legs,
but what it seems to mean more
accurately is that whatever it is that
makes you conscious has this divine
quality and it's capable of extracting
order continually from payoffs.
And by doing that,
by being conscious actors in the world,
you're bringing about the creation of
reality.
And that's a remarkable thing.
And you know,
there's,
there's nothing,
there's nothing mystical about that you
know perfectly well that you can make
tomorrow one thing or another,
you know,
and is that freewill?
Well,
who,
who knows that question will never be
solved,
but it certainly seems phenomenal,
logically like there's an option here
for you and there's an option here for
you and there's an option here for you.
Those are all potential and you can just
choose which one of those you want to
head towards and make actual and that's
consciousness.
Doing that consciousness is something we
don't have a clue vote and this is
William James.
William James is the father of a
pragmatic philosophy,
but also with modern psychology.
He did a fair bit of experimentation
with nitrous oxide,
which is this sort of inert gas that,
that the dentists use,
for example,
as an animal analgesic,
but that also has quite profound
hallucinatory and mystical experience
inducing properties.
And so William James used to play with
this.
This is a poem he,
he wrote,
um,
I'll read the description description
first from William James and then the
poem he said,
pure experiences,
the name which I give to the original
flux of life before reflection has
categorized it.
Only newborn Babes and persons in semi
coma from sleep,
drugs,
illnesses,
or blows can have an experience pure in
the literal sense
of that which is not yet any definite
what they'll ready to be.
All sorts of what's full,
both of oneness and of meanness,
but in respects that don't appear
changing throughout yet.
So confusedly that it's phases,
interpenetrate and no points either of
distinction or of identity can be
caught.
Sorry,
I.
Yeah,
well it's sort of an incoherent,
but what William James is referring to
is this idea that what the ground of
reality as something like a potential
from a potential full of many possible
actualities from which single
actualities can be drawn and that that's
what consciousness is doing would it
makes decisions and it's.
It's a brilliant idea and I think you
know,
and I expect you to take this with a
grain of salt because I know this part
of what I'm telling you about what you
may think this about.
A lot of what I'm telling you is sort of
out on the fringes,
but the quantum mechanics believed that
the most accurate way to portray the
ground of reality is as something that
striving to manifest itself.
It's not there yet.
It has to be interacted with something
that's a conscious observer before it
takes on tangible reality.
And so the ground of being seems to be
something like,
like a multidimensional potential from
which many things can emerge.
And I think I actually think that is
what we see when we look at the future,
you know,
because what the hell is the future?
What is it?
You know,
we certainly treated it as if it's real.
The future is a place of potential wild,
right?
Well,
what does that mean?
it means whatever it means is real
enough so that you orient yourself by it
and you take the future seriously.
You believe your choice is bringing
future a,
future b and two being you don't really
know the limits of that.
You know,
like if you really got your act together
right down to the core,
you know,
you have no idea what sort of glorious
future you might be able to bring into
existence.
You know,
it's,
it's an an resolve question.
If you diligently work with all of your
effort,
you know,
to perfecting the things around you,
you have no idea how far you might be
able to go.
You don't want it to.
It's a real open question and I think
that's part of what human beings have to
bring against the sort of horrors of
existence.
It's like you have a lot of potential
and if you made the right choices,
if we're awake and careful,
God only knows what you might be able to
manage.
So here's this poem.
He sounds like a sixties hippy from
Greenwich village,
really written in like 1890.
No verbiage can give it because the
verbiage is either by which he means
that whatever this potential is exists
in a place before articulation,
right?
Once it's articulated,
it's not potential,
it's all of a sudden something actual.
That's actually why the ancient Jews
didn't want to use the name of God.
You weren't allowed to name God because
as soon as you named God,
he was no longer God.
God was the unnameable.
You know,
in the and the,
and the Muslims have the same sort of
idea about Mohammed in many ways.
It's like you don't,
don't want to make out concrete
representation because then you take the
ideal,
the ideal space,
and you start to make it something that
you can like our human construction.
So you know,
it's an idea of this quarter.
It's merit.
No verbiage can give it because the
verbiage just other incoherent,
coherent the same and it fades and it's
infinite.
It's infinite.
Don't you see the difference?
Don't you see the identity constantly?
Opposites united the same me telling you
to write a note to write extreme
something other than that thing.
Intoxication and other.
This intoxication,
every attempted betterment,
every attempted other men.
It is,
it fades forever and forever as we move.
Alright,
let's start there.
Obviously.